[Música]
un pequeño país de 2.8 millones de
habitantes ubicado en el mar Báltico ha
desafiado a la gigantesca y poderosa
China de más de 1.400 millones de
habitantes estoy hablando de lituania un
país integrante de la Unión Europea que
ha estrechado su relación con Taiwán
causando molestia en Beijing vamos al
contexto para entender Por qué es tan
significativo lo que está sucediendo y
la atención entre estos dos países el
gobierno de Taiwán Isla que china
considera como parte de su territorio
abrió una oficina de representación en
vilna en consecuencia china entonces
retiró a su embajador en lituania desde
entonces el comercio entre ambos países
ha venido en caída hablo entre lituania
y China es por eso que la Unión Europea
en defensa de lituania acusó a China de
prácticas discriminatorias por negarse a
importar bienes lituanos dado que la
situación no mejoró Bruselas entonces
decidió demandar a China ante la
Organización Mundial del Comercio para
instaurar esta demanda contó con el
apoyo unánime de los 27 países de la
Unión Europea acto seguido lituania fue
eliminada del sistema de despachos de
aduanas de China Beijing también
suspendió los trenes de mercancías con
destino al país Báltico
esto indicó también que el retiro de
lituania del sistema de aduanas se debía
a un error en los sistemas por lo menos
eso fue lo que dijeron desde Beijing
tratando de mitigar un poco la situación
pero Tal parece que no fue un error
cerrar las líneas de crédito para las
empresas lituanas el resultado de todas
estas medidas tomadas por Beijing pues
una caída del 91% de las exportaciones
de lituania hacia China la cereza del
pastel cuál fue Pues fue la sanción
impuesta por Beijing a la vicepresidenta
de transporte y comunicaciones de
lituania por haber realizado una visita
oficial a Taiwán
no conforme con esto En días pasados
también letonia y Estonia que son países
vecinos de lituania anunciaron su retiro
del foro respaldado por China de un foro
que fue creado para impulsar las
relaciones entre países de Europa del
este y Beijing pero para esta decisión
los dos países o los últimos dos países
que optaron por retirarse tuvieron como
base esa tensión que existe entre
lituania y China parece que esto pues
representa un revés entonces en la
diplomacia china por lo menos en esta
zona del Báltico los gobiernos de riga y
detalina argumentaron que su retiro
también se debía a que china se ha
fortalecido a nivel internacional ya ha
fortalecido sobre todo sus relaciones
con Rusia cuya invasión a Ucrania ha
sido interpretada por los países
bálticos como un primer paso de una
serie de acciones militares contra otros
países que en algún momento en el pasado
fueron parte de la unión soviética en el
por otro lado de la moneda china no ha
criticado a Rusia no a condenado las
acciones militares en Ucrania no ha
condenado la invasión en el este de
Ucrania Eso sí ha condenado las
sanciones económicas impuestas por
Europa y Estados Unidos a Rusia los
estados bálticos desafían a China A qué
precio Lo vamos a analizar en el debate
de France 24 para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Patricio Houston
él es consultor político director del
observatorio chino argentino y docentes
del posgrado sobre china contemporánea
de la Universidad Católica Argentina la
uca
también hemos invitado a Andrés servín
el doctor en ciencias políticas y
analista internacional es presidente del
Tin Tank regional Cris les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Instagram y en Facebook en donde no se
encuentran como arroba
france24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 ya usted la conoce también
les recuerdo que en YouTube ustedes
pueden seguir nuestras señal en
streaming y pueden dejar sus comentarios
en el chat en vivo también saludo a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de a través del podcast nos
pueden escuchar tenemos todos los
contenidos de El Debate disponibles en
diferentes plataformas ya ustedes las
ven en pantalla Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
comienza entonces con Patricio dándole
la bienvenida al programa Patricio
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos hoy
abordar este tema interesante entender
porque estos tres países le están
generando problemas diplomáticos y
comerciales a China y ese es mi Punto de
partida la pregunta para conocer
posiciones de los invitados tres estados
muy pequeños tal vez de poca importancia
a nivel comercial a nivel mundial si uno
lo compara contra china pero están
desafiando al gigante comercial del
momento del presente una lucha David y
Goliat que se puede decir sobre esto
Muchas gracias por la invitación y
efectivamente si uno toma el tamaño de
estos países son pequeños a nivel
mundial pero incluso dentro de lo que es
el marco europeo Este es un golpe
simbólico hay que verlo desde el
simbolismo geopolítico es un nuevo golpe
que sufre la estrategia de china en
Europa
pequeños países que no es casual que
sean ellos quienes Quienes se revelan
por cuestiones que tienen que ver más en
este momento con lo que es la guerra en
Ucrania la necesidad de un mayor
alineamiento de la política de estos
países con lotan y con los Estados
Unidos y la oportunidad para de alguna
forma
desligarse o dar un paso al frente en el
marco de este foro que era el 17 más uno
que ahora queda de alguna forma
conformado por solamente 14 países donde
china realmente no había podido
prosperar demasiado en sus proyectos en
los últimos años y si ahora Obviamente
le sumamos a esta poca
avances económicos la fuga directamente
de países estamos como decía al
principio ante un golpe muy fuerte para
la estrategia de China
ahora saludó a Andrés también allí en
Argentina para preguntarle El Punto de
partida estos tres países bálticos
pequeños integrantes de la Unión Europea
ex repúblicas soviéticas una historia
muy particular que ya vamos a
profundizar en la relación que tiene ese
pasado histórico con la unión soviética
y lo que está viviendo Taiwán hoy en el
presente su opinión sobre este desafío
si se le puede llamar así desafío por lo
menos desde el lado de lituania a China
Bueno gracias por la invitación saludo a
Patricio y coincido con él en algo de lo
que había comentado recientemente yo
creo que esto es un mensaje más de
carácter político que de carácter
económico de hecho el intercambio
comercial entre los países del foro en
general era bastante favorable a los
países del foro en el intercambio
comercial con China y con excepción de
algunos casos muy particulares Y en este
contexto Más allá de la situación
específica de Taiwán yo creo que hay un
proceso de alineamiento en torno a lo
que está pasando con la transición
Global en general y los distintos
alianzas que se establecen en ese
contexto evidentemente una respuesta
China tiene que ver mucho con la
posición de china con respecto a Rusia
particularmente para estos países
bálticos que son
especialmente sensibles frente a lo que
es la guerra Ucrania y la política
exterior rusa
Andrés continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa hay un término que
surgió mientras hacía la investigación
sobre este tema que me llamó la atención
y es el chinocentrismo china tratando de
volverse el punto estratégico del
comercio mundial y por eso pues su
respuesta a estas discrepancias con
vilna con y con riga y con tallin
siempre La respuesta es en términos
económicos y en términos comerciales
china está intentando
volverse ese punto focal del comercio
internacional si es que ya no lo es de
que el comercio gire en torno a ellos y
esto es una muestra de eso
Yo creo que esa visión del sinocentrismo
en realidad pasa por un proceso más
complejo en realidad yo creo que estamos
viviendo un proceso de desglobalización
y en todo caso de formulación O
desarrollo de dos estrategias de
globalización distintas uno en lo que es
el ámbito occidental y tiene mucho que
ver también con la confrontación con
Rusia y otro es cómo se está
desarrollando en el ámbito euroasiático
particularmente en el marco de
instituciones como la organización de
cooperación de Shanghai y la misma
articulación entre la ruta
de la seda y la unión económica
euroasiática
estamos viviendo un proceso de
segmentación o fragmentación en lo que
ha sido la globalización como le hemos
visto hasta ahora en alto margen de
interdependencia y desde luego en este
marco la aspiración de China que era
llegar a través de la beltard nuevo
hasta los mercados europeos se ve
crecientemente afectada Pero esto tiene
que ver también con la posición política
muy clara geopolítica
de alineación con Rusia en la situación
de Ucrania Patricio su opinión sobre
este tema esto es netamente político
obedece a esa posición de China frente a
Rusia china ha dicho que todas estas
medidas que ha tomado frente al comercio
con lituania son respuestas que no
tienen carácter político sino un
carácter que parte desde las mismas
empresas pero hay que entender que china
es un país con una economía comunista
abierta con toques muy capitalistas una
economía como de Mercado pero muy
controlada por el estado que quien Toma
las decisiones pues es el gobierno de
China no las empresas de una manera
Autónoma que puede decir usted
no Por supuesto que el trasfondo es
político y voy a coincidir ahí con lo
que decía Andrés lo que está haciendo
China de alguna forma es aleccionar a
quienes intentan desafiarla con algunos
temas que son sensibles el caso previo
es el de Australia es el primer caso
modelico que tenemos de lo que china va
a ser Leo de la forma en que china va a
responder ante países que decidan
abiertamente criticar o desafiar cierto
fundamentos de su política exterior en
el caso de Europa el interés de China
tiene un componente geopolítico pero yo
te diría que es más bien económico
siempre lo ha sido en el marco de lo que
es la Bed And Roll iniciative y ahí es
donde china como decía anteriormente
acumula frustraciones el acuerdo
comercial y de inversiones con la Unión
Europea está congelado Por supuesto que
la guerra en Ucrania tenía mucho que ver
con esto con que esto se termine de
estancar pero ahora el desgranamiento de
este foro que era el principal marco de
cooperación que tenía China
Europa por lo menos con los países de
Europa del este también es una es un
golpe del que china difícilmente pueda
recuperarse mientras se mantenga este
contexto internacional que también
describía Andrés en el Mientras tanto
china le estando énfasis a la
organización de cooperación de Shanghai
para hacerse fuerte desde esos foros
multilaterales alternativos a la visión
y a los principios de occidente no China
tiene en donde refugiarse usted lo está
explicando Patricio pero que hay de
lituania Más allá de pertenecer a la
Unión Europea que está ese tratado libre
comercio entre Bruselas y Beijing pues
prácticamente congelado por la coyuntura
que hay en este momento pero qué tanto
está perdiendo lituania al tener esta
distanciamiento con la potencia
comercial de el planeta y cuando vemos a
otros países de Europa tanto de la Unión
Europea como fuera de la Unión Europea
completamente desesperados para que
china vaya a invertir vaya a mejorar la
infraestructura vaya a prolongar la ruta
de la seda un poco más hasta el centro
de Europa y no sé qué tan en la puerta
de los balcanes sino que se extienda más
allá y lituania simplemente le dice pues
yo prefiero acercarme a Taiwán
bueno en el caso de lituania que también
podemos extenderlo a los otros países
del Báltico son pequeños países que
venían explorando un acercamiento con
china sobre todo basado en el
pragmatismo comercial pero lo que nunca
fueron tan dependientes Como por ejemplo
hoy es Alemania fijémonos que es una
paradoja Alemania quizás el país más
importante de hoy económicamente y
políticamente también de la Unión
Europea no tiene el grado de libertad
para alejarse de China como si pueden
tener estos pequeños países del Báltico
que claramente tienen más margen de
maniobra para mi entender según Mi
humilde opinión muy arriesgado
recostándose tanto sobre Estados Unidos
y también en este caso jugando con la
cuestión de Taiwán que eso es una
provocación abierta pero no seamos
ingenuos yo creo que ningún movimiento
de estos países
digamos está exento de un cierto aval de
Washington esto es clarísimo tenemos que
decirlo pero bueno no deja de ser un
movimiento arriesgado jugar tan fuerte
en el marco de la disputa geopolítica en
este caso inclinándose hacia el bando
entre comillas de los Estados Unidos
veremos veremos como esto se desarrolla
en el corto plazo no A3 en ese contexto
qué tan beneficioso puede ser para
lituania en este caso en particular que
es el que pues más compleja tiene la
situación con Beijing acercarse a Taiwán
en la coyuntura en la que está en este
momento abrir es oficina de
representación en vilna empezar a
acercarse comercialmente hablaba yo de
la viceministra de transporte y
comunicaciones que fue a taipei fue
sancionada por Beijing que tanto están
ahí jugando con fuego y qué tan
beneficioso puede ser Taiwán en este
momento
Bueno yo creo que estamos en la en una
situación en donde crecientemente
los alineamientos a nivel internacional
implican compromisos de un lado y del
otro que rompen compromisos anteriores
Entonces en ese contexto evidentemente
los países bálticos y en particular
lituania al establecer una relación más
estrecha con Taiwán está marcando una
definición muy clara en cuanto a su
identificación no solamente con
occidente con los intereses Estados
Unidos con la Unión Europea sino no los
olvidemos con el hecho de que pertenece
a la otan conjuntamente con nosotros dos
países bálticos Entonces esto de alguna
manera insisto
señala es un que la posición frente a lo
que está sucediendo en Ucrania frente a
Rusia de estos países que
tradicionalmente se han visto amenazados
después del desmoronamiento de la unión
soviética por Rusia es bueno nosotros
estamos alineados claramente con
occidente
Y eventualmente si hay una alianza Una
convergencia entre China y Rusia
nosotros respondemos en términos de una
mayor vinculación con aquellos que son
aliados de occidente obviamente Taiwán
es uno de ellos claro importante también
analizar Andrés ya que hablábamos de ese
tratado libre comercio paralizado entre
la Unión Europea y China la demanda que
la Unión Europea de forma unánime por
consenso de los 27 países instauró a
China en el marco de la omc por
boicotear a los productos lituanos y por
considerar que realiza prácticas
discriminatorias incluso esta práctica
ha afectado productos que son hechos en
Suecia en Dinamarca o en Alemania que
cuentan con componentes lituanos que
también han empezado a ser vetados en el
mercado chino por tener simplemente
componentes lituanos aquí un escenario
de disputa Bruselas Beijing esto puede
crecer esto afectará esa posibilidad de
ponerle Punto de partida a la
negociación de ese tratado libre
comercio que puede representar esta
demanda pero yo creo que va a crecer la
atención en la misma medida que también
hay una expectativa por parte de la
Unión Europea de avanzar un comercio más
intenso con
con en torno a los Microchips producidos
en Taiwán Esto está por verse para eso
se requiere una situación Más estable
pero está planteado y también la
búsqueda de inversiones ahora lo que yo
creo que hay que tener muy claro es que
estamos frente como se plantea con
frecuencia a una confrontación híbrida
Entre dos mundos si esta confrontación
híbrida se desarrolla en un plano
económico principalmente entre aquellos
actores que juegan duro o fuerte en el
plano económico Pero puede llevar a otro
tipo de confrontaciones en otro ámbito
desde el ámbito digital hasta el ámbito
eminentemente bélico como lo estamos
viendo en el caso de Entonces yo yo
insisto en esto que estamos frente a un
cisma a una fragmentación muy clara del
sistema internacional en dos bandos
quizás con algunos focos alternos que
puedan dar la idea de un mundo
multipolar Pero principalmente donde en
la confrontaciones entre estos dos
bandos se van a dar en muchísimos planos
y uno de ellos principalmente por las
características de los autos de los
actores las Unión Europea y China es el
plano comercial y financiero
Patricio recojo las palabras de Andrés
cisma dos bandos su opinión sobre esta
perspectiva
Sí yo creo yo siempre Insisto que el
conflicto entre China y Estados Unidos
hay que verlo en función de sus
diferentes dimensiones no podemos
olvidarnos que el comercio bilateral
entre China y Estados Unidos está en
torno a los 500 mil millones de dólares
es y va a seguir siendo probablemente
por mucho tiempo la mayor relación
comercial bilateral de la historia en
términos de interdependencia comercial
hay muchas cosas que van a seguir
tensionándose pero no va a haber un gran
cambio en este sentido y lo mismo pasa
con una situación incluso de mayor
debilidad relativa entre la Unión
Europea y China por eso tú preguntabas
antes qué va a pasar con lituania es una
solidaridad que tiene patas cortas Me
parece que la Unión Europea ni siquiera
en su conjunto están capacidad de
tensionar demasiado la cuerda en ese
plano con china ahora bien lo
tecnológico el tema derechos humanos los
geopolíticos que estaban muy relacionado
en este momento a lo que pasa en el del
sur de la China y Taiwán en eso sí Yo
creo que vamos a ver una atención
creciente Y probablemente una Unión
Europea dispuesta a jugarse un poco más
como ya estamos viendo en algunos
comunicados y en algunas expresiones de
diplomáticos importantes incluso de
jefes de estado Así que hay que saber
ver las distintas dimensiones para poder
comprender en profundidad lo que está
sucediendo bueno es que para una Unión
Europea que es tan burocrática y tan
lenta en términos diplomáticos para
actuar que siempre ha sido la gran
crítica la Unión Europea que se demora
mucho en tomar decisiones haber llevado
una demanda ante la omc contra china ya
es un paso grande y es un paso
representativo y poniendo muchísimo en
riesgo en términos comerciales Andrés
Patricio usted citaba el caso de
Australia en 2020 lo retomo rápidamente
en el marco de la pandemia de Kobe 19
Australia pidió que hubiera una
investigación más profunda para
determinar el origen de la pandemia en
China esto a Beijing por supuesto No le
gustó Y entonces este juego de importar
diferentes productos entre ellos el vino
australiano que tiene un grandísimo
mercado en China y ahí empezaron estas
discrepancias entre canberra y Beijing
vemos este escenario en los países
bálticos puede haber otro Rincón del
planeta que está en una situación
similar que pueda tener una atención
parecida
no sé se me viene la cabeza patricios no
sé usted qué piensa que Paraguay por
ejemplo sigue reconociendo a China a
Taiwán no reconoce a China y eso
dificulta las negociaciones de Uruguay
con China para stlc y lo que representa
el mercosur no sé eso puede generar hay
tensiones tal vez
en el caso de Paraguay no lo creo porque
es un estatus quo que se mantiene el
reconocimiento de Taiwán y de hecho
Bueno hay que decir también que Taiwán
le exporta soja y otros productos a
China a través de triangulaciones Esto
es algo vox populi que se conoce en el
seno del mercosur históricamente
lo que china castiga son los desafíos
abiertos sobre temas sensibles como
decía y efectivamente cuando hay
amenazas de cambio de estatus quo como
en el caso de lituania La amenaza puede
abrir una oficina comercial le cuento
que por ejemplo la Argentina tiene una
oficina comercial y cultural de estas
características y hay muchísimos otros
países que las tienen el problema son
los cambios de estatus quo en este
contexto yo creo que ahí china va a
seguir mostrando su inflexibilidad y va
a castigar en principio con herramientas
comerciales ejerciendo el poder
asimétrico tan fuerte que tiene en su
favor fijémonos incluso frente a
Australia que es una potencia media
importante ni hablar si hay algún país
de latinoamérica o de África que se
anima a desafiarla yo creo que va a
sufrir las consecuencias por supuesto de
manera mucho más contundente pero como
bien tú dices tenemos que prestar
atención a distintos lugares del mundo
creo que esto no va a quedar acostado
solamente a lo que está sucediendo con
los países bálticos sí desafíos puede
haber en otros rincones del planeta
Andrés esta situación me recuerda
también a muchas críticas que hacía en
su momento Rusia que hacía en su momento
china a Estados Unidos por desafiar o
castigar de aquellos países que no se
alineaban con sus teorías o con sus
perspectivas sobre diferentes
situaciones en el mundo esta teoría de
estás conmigo o desconfío de ti tanto
que lo criticó china tanto que lo
criticó Rusia y china en este caso está
actuando Exactamente igual
sí lo que sucede es que estamos en una
coyuntura ya distinta no todos
necesariamente se ven obligados a
alinearse 100% con alguno de estos dos
polos no eventualmente voy a dar dos
ejemplos uno es el caso de la india que
tiene relaciones comerciales muy
estrechas con china pero tiene una
disputa territorial y a la vez tiene una
relación estrecha con Rusia pero
pertenece al quad que es un cuadrilátero
de seguridad tiene en el mar de la china
en eso de estas asiático y en donde
participa conjuntamente con Japón
Estados Unidos y Australia en este
esquema el otro caso es la asociación de
estados del sudeste asiático que
encabezados por Indonesia en su momento
tratan de mantener un equilibrio en sus
relaciones muy estrechas desde el punto
de vista económico con china pero
también resguardarse desde el punto de
vista de seguridad con una cercanía
mayor con Estados Unidos entonces hay
situaciones muy ambiguas y desde luego
que la polarización fuerza que algunos
de estos actores tenga que verse
obligado a tomar partido en un lado en
el otro pero en general hay estrategias
de no alineamiento muy importante
importante ese punto está claro Andrés
creo que es importante también Andrés y
lo explicaba yo en la introducción del
programa que los argumentos de Estonia y
de letonia para salirse de este foro de
cooperación con china era justamente la
estrecha relación que hay entre China y
Rusia sobre todo a raíz de la invasión a
el este de Ucrania creo que es
importante aclarar y poner aquí sobre el
debate y sobre la mesa de análisis Cuál
es ese pasado que tienen en común estas
tres repúblicas bálticas y Rusia y
entonces la unión soviética Y por qué
siempre estos tres países miran con
temor todos los movimientos que da Moscú
en todos los ámbitos siempre se mira con
desconfianza los movimientos del krem y
pues ni que se diga después de que
invadieron el este de Ucrania A qué le
temen ellos por qué tanto temor a Rusia
Bueno hay una historia historial de
agravios en términos de ocupaciones y de
intervenciones por parte de Rusia en los
territorios la bálticos eso es una zona
incluyendo Ucrania desde luego una zona
muy sensible en términos de los
movimientos de expansión en su momento
desde el Imperio ruso para acá de lo que
fue Rusia ahora lo que pasa que hay un
temor muy específico y por eso la
referencia a la Guerra de Ucrania Me
parece muy importante y a China en
particular en este contexto Y es que en
los últimos 20 años había una
convergencia estratégica crucial entre
Rusia y China hemos visto eso en como
china se ha obtenido del condenar a
Rusia en el caso de Ucrania y ahora lo
vamos a ver en los próximos días hay un
ejercicio militar conjunto entre China y
Rusia esto no significa que tenga una
alianza militar pero sí que están
alineados en una de convergencia en el
ámbito internacional a lo cual yo
agregaría un elemento que no tenemos
tiempo para discutir ahora pero que es
muy importante en el esfuerzo que están
haciendo ambos países con conjuntamente
con otros actores euroasiáticos en la
generación de un espacio desdolarizado
en el ámbito de grosiático Y esto es un
elemento de contrapeso y a la vez de
toma de distancia con respecto a
occidente que evidentemente afecta a los
países más sensibles que han tenido una
historial como decía de agravios por
parte de algunos de estos actores
Patricio su opinión sobre este tema y
extiende un poco el comentario y la
pregunta
lituania ha dicho que encuentra muchas
similitudes entre lo que le sucedió a su
pueblo en al final de la década de los
30 cuando fue ocupada por las fuerzas
soviéticas y anexada a la unión
soviética como una experiencia similar
como a lo que viven los oigures en China
como lo que viven los tibetanos y lo que
han vivido recientemente con las
manifestaciones y represión en Hong Kong
hay temor por parte de lituania que esto
pueda suceder en un futuro por parte de
Rusia que los puede invadir que este
escenario pueda ocurrir Y por qué la
crítica internacional y el peso sobre
china por estos casos en particular que
le menciono es tan poca si se la reclama
pero nadie castiga a China por eso
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que no son
casos comparables la situación de las
etnias minoritarias en China y lo que
sucede en un área administrativa
especial que es soberanía de China como
es Hong Kong no que de hecho fue un
enclave colonial durante mucho tiempo
ocupado en este caso por el Reino Unido
y que fue devuelto a China con lo que
fueron las invasiones de como decía
Andrés no sobre todo en la etapa zarista
algunos territorios que hoy son
repúblicas independientes a veces son
situaciones históricas y geopolíticas
muy diferentes que podríamos cometer o
llegar a conclusiones cerradas al
compararlo por ejemplo cuando se compara
Ucrania con Taiwán son también dos
situaciones diferentes por más que hoy
solidarizarse con Taiwán sería como un
sinónimo desde la postura de estos
países con solidarizarse con lo que
están sufriendo los ucranianos
Por eso hay que tener en cuenta todas
esas cuestiones históricas
para para poder ser justos con el
análisis y comprender lo que está lo que
está sucediendo pero efectivamente estos
países hoy quiero volver a este punto se
sienten desprotegidos se sienten una
situación de de protección y frente a la
posible amenaza de una invasión en un
futuro no muy lejano hoy Efectivamente
es un escenario que estos pequeños
países no contemplaban hace un año
quizás y hoy está como una una de sus
máximas preocupaciones y eso también es
atendible y tienen sus fundamentos
también para pensar en ese sentido no
Patricio pero no es similar por ejemplo
estos anuncios que ha hecho
recientemente el gobierno chino de tomar
parte de la población tibetana cerca del
Asa y desplazarla hacia otros puntos del
país supuestamente para alejarlos de
esos puntos que ellos llaman puntos de
pobreza porque la son zonas poco
desarrolladas y moverlos hacia otras
zonas y ocuparlas con población china
como hacía este momento la unión
soviética cuando hacía el proceso de
rusificación Tal vez por eso es que
existe esa ese espejo tal vez de los
países bálticos con lo que sucede con
estas minorías al interior de China y
hasta en cierto punto con con Taiwán
bueno primero porque no conteste una de
las cuestiones que me has dicho
anteriormente realmente hay un
criticismo creciente sobre china
obviamente uno puede decir todavía son
voces tenues no hay mucha concordancia
en los foros internacionales pero china
está recibiendo un nivel de criticismo
sobre ciertas cuestiones que tienen que
ver con esto sobre todo derechos humanos
que nunca había recibido y está
respondiendo no con cada vez más dureza
hay una nuevo estilo de diplomacia que
se llama del lobo Guerrero efectivamente
estamos viendo más
contraataque y una agresividad creciente
por parte de China y sí hay pues
políticas económicas y en términos
poblacionales adentro de China que son
muy controversiales esto que tú decidas
población china en realidad te refiere
esa población de la etnia hana que es la
etnia mayoritaria casi el 90% de la
población eso es cierto hay toda una
política para que haya más población y
obviamente la población que china
intenta desplazar como es
mayoritariamente el 90% han son
básicamente
hannes no lo que empiezan a evitar esos
lugares con toda la controversia que
ellos lleva y efectivamente es un tema
interno es un tema que se está
discutiendo internamente también en
China por supuesto con mucho hermetismo
es difícil que eso trascienda pero es un
tema conflictivo y de debate hoy dentro
de China esto que está sucediendo
Andrés Patricio Ya llegamos a la parte
final del programa quiero ir cerrando
Todavía no hago conclusiones pero quiero
ir tocando este tema para el cierre y Es
sobre la diplomacia China y la forma en
que china se ha aproximado al mundo y se
ha aproximado a estos países en África
para fomentar el desarrollo sobre todo
el desarrollo de infraestructura y
también a países como estos tres estados
bálticos tal vez esté estas grietas que
se abrieron con Australia con estos
estados bálticos con esta
distanciamiento que hay allí son el
inicio de pequeñas grietas de esa forma
de diplomacia China de llegar
agresivamente a invadir los mercados a
ofrecer manufactura buenos precios el
traslado de fábricas hacia su territorio
para producción a mejores precios y
también para ofrecer la construcción de
infraestructura A muy buenos precios y
ofrecer créditos muy favorables es
momento tal vez para que Beijing se
replantee su diplomacia otra forma de
aproximación o remozar un poco su
diplomacia
A mi manera de ver esto lo vamos a ver
dentro de tres meses cuando se produzcan
la Cumbre del partido comunista chino y
se decida si efectivamente si jinping va
a tercer tener un tercer mandato Y ahí
sí vamos a ver cómo se materializan
algunas de los elementos que están
asomando en este momento en la
estrategia de proyección global de China
hasta ese momento creo que es difícil
apreciar con Claridad Y cuánto puede
acentuarse una política mucho más
proactiva de China digamos en en el
ámbito internacional Más allá de lo que
estamos viendo hasta este momento y
Patricio su opinión momento de hacerle
algunos cambios ajustes al Estado
diplomacia tal vez pensar en nuevas
estrategias nuevas formas de aproximarse
recuperar terrenos perdidos Australia
recuperar el Báltico
le puso mute al micrófono y no lo vimos
Patricio
independientemente de lo que suceda en
el congreso del partido donde
efectivamente lo más probable es que el
presidente sí sea rr electo ya Hay
ciertos ajustes y replanteos en la
diplomática hacia china primero es una
diplomacia que sale de la pasividad y
bajo perfil y contraataca y con dureza
como estábamos hablando y segundo hay
una evaluación crítica sobre los avances
de la nueva ruta de la seda los
proyectos No avanzaron como china
esperaba Sí hay muchos países con
problemas como con Pakistán que son
países importantes en el marco de este
proyecto donde china encontró enormes
dificultades muchas críticas
internacionales Y entonces seguramente
ya está sucediendo eso hay un replanteo
de la forma en la que china va a
financiar y se va a relacionar con sus
principales socios comerciales y eso nos
va a impactar a todos incluido a
latinoamérica también claramente porque
es un importante socio comercial ya para
la región de América Latina si es que ya
no es el principal socio comercial de
muchos los países de América Latina Me
quedan pocos minutos para la conclusión
Patricio Andrés para cerrar el tema
Entonces qué va a pasar en los próximos
meses veremos escenarios similares esto
es un Punto de partida para generar
tensiones ya lo decíamos en otros puntos
de el planeta su gran conclusión sobre
este tema comienzo con Andrés
yo creo que vamos a tener un incremento
de las situaciones de tensión y de
fricción creo que en la percepción de
los analistas nos equivocamos en su
momento porque pensábamos que el
estallido la eclosión de estas tensiones
se iba a dar en el ámbito de lindo
Pacífico y se dio primero en el
escenario europeo Pero eso no quiere
decir que no volvamos a ese ámbito en su
momento y hay que tener en cuenta que
esta esta fragmentación que yo señalaba
va a incrementar las tensiones Estos son
como las placas tectónicas que empiezan
a moverse y empiezan a generar roces
entre sí Y ahí no sabemos qué es lo que
puede llegar a suceder en términos de un
escalamiento de las tensiones y de Las
Rosas y Patricio su conclusión para el
cierre del programa
coincido con Andrés yo creo que vamos un
mundo de mayor tensión por estos temas
creo que no quiero ser muy tremendista
no pero estamos a las puertas de un
mundo desconocido por cómo se está dando
el conflicto entre China Estados Unidos
situaciones como la guerra en Ucrania el
impacto económico de la pandemia la
conformación de nuevos bloques
multilaterales que están en colisión en
muchas cuestiones estamos ante un mundo
que seguramente va a ser muy conflictivo
y más imprevisible donde van a suceder
seguramente otro tipo de incidente como
lo que estamos viendo y va a haber
tensión creciente hacia el interior de
los distintos bloques que se van
conformando con una disputa que no está
Clara como se va a resolver entre China
y los Estados Unidos Ojalá que se
mantengan los planos de lo comercial y
lo tecnológico y no pase al plano que
nadie quiere me entiendo que nadie
quiere que lleguemos a ese punto que es
el del choque militar No es cierto es
que hay muchas cosas en el momento
transcurriendo en diferentes puntos del
planeta a nivel político a nivel
social cultural y pues bueno las
consecuencias las estaremos viendo en un
futuro cercano ya veremos En qué termina
toda esta historia Andrés Patricio les
agradezco Muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de Francia 24
el nombre de todo el equipo técnico del
debate de France 24 les agradezco su
sintonía y Pueden seguir viendo frases
[Música]